so there's this
richness of life in a single drink of
water that you experience
and then there's this power of nature
that's it capable
to take lives of thousands of people so
given all that the absurdity of that
let me ask you and the fact that you
study
things that could kill the entirety of
human civilization
what do you think is the meaning of this
all what do you think is the meaning of
life
this whole orchestra we got going on
does it have a meaning
and maybe from another perspective as
how does one live a meaningful life if
such is possible
well you know from what i've seen uh
i don't think there's a single answer to
that by any stretch one of the most
interesting things about buddhism to me
is that
the human existence is part of suffering
which is very different from
judeo-christian existence which is that
human
existence is um something to be
uh is a very different you know it's
something to it's a
there's a richness to it in buddhism
it's just another
one of your lives and it but it's your
opportunity
to attain nirvana and uh
become a monk for example and meditate
to attain nirvana
uh else you kind of just go back into
this i'm sorry the cycle of
of suffering and so you know
when i look at i mean in some ways uh
the notion of
life and what the purpose of life is
you know they're kind of completely
distinct this sort of western view of
life which is that this
life is the most precious thing in the
world versus
this is just another opportunity to try
to
get out of life i mean the whole notion
of nirvana and in buddhism it getting
out of
this sort of cycle of suffering is to
vanish you know what if you could
if you could attain nirvana you know
throughout this life the idea is that
you don't get reborn
and so when i look at these two you know
on the one hand you have
christian you know christian faith and
other things that want to go to
heaven and like live forever in heaven
then you have this other whole
half of humans who uh want nothing more
than to
get out of the cycle of rebirth and just
poof you know
not exist anymore the cycle of suffering
yeah and so how do you reconcile those
two and i guess
do you have both of them in you do you
basically oscillate back and forth
i don't think i i think i just i i look
at us in a
i think we're just a bunch of proteins
um
that you know we form and we've they
work in this really
amazing way and they might work in a
bigger scale like there might be some
connections that we're not really clear
about but they're still biological i
believe that they're biological
how do these proteins become conscious
and why do they want to
help civilization by having at home
rapid tests at scale well i think
um i don't have an answer to that one
but i
i really do believe i would it's just uh
you know this is just an evolution of
uh consciousness i don't i don't
personally think is
my feeling is that we're a bunch of
pluses and minuses that have just gotten
so complex that
they're able to make rich feelings rich
emotions and
and i do believe though you know on the
one hand i sometimes wake up
some days um my fiancee doesn't always
love it but you know i kind of think
world's a bunch of robots with like
pretty complicated
algorithms that we deal with yeah um
and you know in that sense like okay if
the world just blew up tomorrow
and no nothing was liv you know nothing
existed the day after that
it's just another blip in the universe
you know but at the same time
i don't know so that's kind of probably
my most core basic feeling about
life is like we're just a blip and we
may as well make the most of it
while we're here blipping but
it's one hell of a fun blip though it is
it's
it's an it's an amazing uh uh you know
blink of a
of an eye in time
you